good days to each and every one
of you I hope that despite the
serious circumstances linked to the
economic and social health crisis of the coc
quickly you were able to take advantage of this summer
to take a little rest
on my side I am happy to  see you
again at the end of this seventh round
of negotiations with the
British team,
we have also maintained very
regular contact with this team with david frost
between us during all
the weeks of August until
Monday and we  we met again this
week to continue our discussions
in person
I would also like to thank the
British team for having made the trip
to Brussels
despite the difficult contexts linked
to the consequences of the empty coc
obviously ladies and gentlemen we will
continue to work intensely
including all the precautions
necessary for our
negotiators during these meetings the
broadcasts there is very little time left
very little time to conclude  re its
negotiations for an agreement comes
into effect on January 1,
in four months and ten days four
nuts and ten days a
complete legal text must be ready by the
end of October at the latest in order to
allow the necessary time to  once
we
cei and the european parliament on our
side to decide we therefore have
about two months left to find an
agreement on all the subjects under
negotiation to consolidate the texts
and settle all the technical appendices
which are not negligible  and then
to check to have
our lawyers check in all the languages and it's
xtremely complex work is es
ential what I simpl
want to say is that any addit
onal delay beyond the end of October would
put us at risk on the
good end to this process
in this context which they were hoping for
those who were expecting an acceleration
of the negotiations this week will be
frankly disappointed with my  on the other hand i am disappointed and
i am also concerned moreover
a little surprised since the
british prime minister boris johnson
had told us in june that he wanted to
speed up our work during the course of
the summer or this week again just like
in  On the occasion of the July rand,
the British negotiators
showed no desire to make progress on
fundamental issues for the
European Union, despite the
flexibility we have shown on the other
hand in recent months to take into account
account and to work on the three
red lines that boris johnson
himself had expressed to us in June on
the role of the european court of justice
on the legislative autonomy of the
united kingdom and on fishing
we still have not seen any  on the
british side a reciprocal effort to
understand european priorities
gold ladies and gentlemen there can
be no surprise no surprise
regarding its priorities of the union
and  european since they have not changed
since 2010 is looked at or reread the
conclusions of the european council the
resolutions of the european parliament
we have been repeating continuously since
2010 are our priorities for an
ambitious balanced agreement with the united kingdom
and with a lot of patience a lot of
patience  we will continue to repeat them until the end
our trade agreement 1
must be accompanied by fair standards and
fair competition
this is what we call
economic and commercial fair play 2
our agreement must guarantee a
fair and sustainable solution over the long term  term
for european anglers right there
will be no changqing there is
no single market card access
since the united kingdom that is the
essence of bric site refuses to accept the
rules and  obligations of this short market
if you minister excites and frankly these
are not dogmatic
technocratic or ideological positions of the
European union it is not d  e
tactic everyone must understand
behind these words behind these requirements
which have been the priorities for
the European Union for four years there are
human, social, economic and
environmental realities which are for us and
which will remain essential for us I
I'm going to take a very concrete example, if you will,
that of
road
transport, which moreover this site at the
moment in the United Kingdom we have seen
in the press in recent days
an emotion that surprises me four years
after the vote of the  breakbeat it amazes me
because this question and the
problems it poses on 10
exactly the consequence of the break site
and nobody should be surprised
by it on the British side road transport
it is a very important economic sector
which represents millions
of  he jobs in europe
is also a sector which has a
direct direct impact on the costs of
logistics for our companies on the
prices paid by consumers.  ers on
pollution on the climate is also on
road safety the
british negotiator does not fly that certain
standards apply to
british road hauliers when they
travel on the territory of the european union
and this has been repeated to us again this
week  in particular on
working time on the installation of
modern tachographs in lorries
to monitor the driving
and rest times of lorry drivers, and they
refuse this progress or these guarantees
while demanding a level of access to
the single market comparable to that  of a
member state all the member states
accept its constraints and its
standards but I repeat in the united kingdom it
has decided itself to leave the single market
the united kingdom has therefore decided itself to
lose the benefits of the single market
it is  his choice it is not our choice
obviously
in any case why should
we give access to our roads to
road hauliers who  would refuse
to apply rules that are
essential for good working conditions
and the safety of all why
should we also allow
British air carriers
to operate the same routes as
European operators if they are not
bound by comparable standards in
protection of the environment
or protection of passengers in the same
spirit
why should we accept that we
see the British being free in
the future to create distortions of
competition against our own
companies,
for example by granting subsidies
or by allocating  derogations in
terms of polluting emissions or
work standards without there being or
a framework of regulatory coherence
it is simply a question of
regulatory coherence between us, to be fixed
in our agreement, see clearly that
behind these words I  Recognize a little
level playing field techno
it's about protecting thousands
of jobs from m  illions of jobs in
each of our states it's about the rights
of our workers our consumers
it's about health it's about
protecting our environment our
president ursula von der leyen has said
clearly we are ready  to
face competition with British companies
provided that this
competition is fair
ladies and gentlemen of need for level
playing field is not going to go and even
the uk continues or a 6 tons locality
agreements and goods and services
only they say non-negotiable price
conditions of the great access to market at
fort un scoundrel fifty million
given citizens of uk geographic proximity
of intensity to economic values and singe
mia asking for nothing more nothi
g less racing res prime minister boyzo
e committed to in a world young people polit
cal declaration last october toget
er we  don't want is heaven is you
lie 2
i'm slave for you knew who is at stake this
word reminders commitment dos de 40  duke
and paramount
by the way and supported by your funk
and also in particular by burning his
26 even when we hagrid in dakota having
future arguments must a compass this
robust robust commitment to prevent
distortion of trade and to prevent
doing so when competitive advantage in
india continued from south coast to prod
common rail stand-up
union applicable and uk said end of transition
period shape right now
they say and laugh side by side
stijn stijnen competition solana
brimstone of environment climate change
and relevant tax matters 10  .6
policy regarding android version
between us and uk covan a
modern artist trade policy is about our
lovering gesture rates in yes moving
quota is about beating finding a dream in
between sovereign parties will save a
catch andrew ladd gaughran future trade
and commissioner  modern french philologist
trade policy m contributor to
for ding ivan resin wright un stand
and interest of cities and consumers in
sustainab  the development yes and 2
discover at consoles nintendo it
sovereignty and rule authorizes autonomy
a yes show clery new international
citrus a 11-0 reach without the
party's at grings just like in red
we the international griment a akan
predict yes absolute all some small
discs  will also be day software
agreements habit uk and other
partners in future 7h united japanese
an australian of 17 young people leave
foundation succession alpiq field style
many other guys who were progressing is
needed and for example obviously
fisheries we have many progressing
whatsoever in 12 steps  matters
governance
we are still pharma grins in
essential ichou between disputes ends
the oin force min whee style streetwear
death grid series
mortgage guarantee citizen fundamentals rights
and personal of state a horizon mobility
and social security coordination or at
the  opposition to olso women far flap of a
dress to be fully objective in ciudad
date sum d  e tnt boys band like vindis
week with the world to make progress in
technical 12 for example in energy
cooperation participation in program
anti money laundering among others 1.18
be useful hated like everything consolidate
together fanal text provide is commendable
and boulder gray to fundamentals first
however any child 18 and
and you have if we were going back words
words and ford who want to showtime
left 4 dead in london in july wiggins
play all age adults a citrus fruit
but in uk radio canut union seems like
and to simply to  not understand why we are
waiting value times and gentlemen
you understood it on the European side
we are concerned about the state of
this negotiation and you forget to
be quite frank we do
not see how pushing back the
most difficult subjects to more  later we could
reach a better agreement we should
however start working on the
consolidation of legal texts
we are ready to do so we had
ns moreover already proposed a complete text
in March
the British also proposed
proposes British texts on
certain subjects but such a
consolidation will only be possible and
useful if it is done together
the British and us and not each
on our side
and  if it is done on all the subjects
in parallel I hope that this point and it
will be well understood we are not there
we are not there since at the time
when I speak to you the only perspective
opened by the British would be
that of a  trade agreement 0 tariff
zero quotas without any credible
level playing field framework and without a
balanced agreement on fishing it is obviously
naturally a logo because it
blocks everything last week
we heard boris johnson reaffirmed
during his meeting with the tee shot
the roles martin his wish to reach
an agreement with the european union
he had already told us and it is also
our wish i think it is still
possible  ble
despite the increasingly short time
and to achieve this, our
British partners will finally have to be ready
to offer us clear and
concrete constructive ideas on the occasion of the
next round to be held in London
from September 7 to 11.  one of the
gentlemen, in parallel with this
difficult very difficult negotiation,
we continue with vice-president
maros sefcovic to be particularly
vigilant for the proper implementation
of the withdrawal agreement by 31
december this year with
regard to the protocol on
ireland of northern ireland
prime
minister bruce johnson's recent statements in belfast
show how sensitive this issue is,
but we expect the
united kingdom to do what is necessary to
ensure the precise and
rigorous implementation of legal obligations  which
are contained for both parties in
this protocol is in the
withdrawal agreement which is today ratified
indeed of its own a  presentation
of works of protocols is the only way
to peer isr highlands
ohlala of economy to protect integrated shooting
of single market and above all to ensure
continue peace un stability and
island va island and in this i want to
pay tribute band the game  all
of education determination of john yum
oussad readers le fiu 8 seconds
with regard to this
withdrawal agreement that we must
implement also with
regard to citizens' rights
we obviously remain
attentive to the proper implementation  implementation on
both sides for european citizens
who live in the united kingdom are very
numerous for british citizens
who live in one of our countries are
also very numerous
we remain attentive to the proper
implementation on both sides of their rights
such  that they are precisely described
in the takeover agreement and for this
we are working in particular
with civil society and with
citizen associations which was
to  lleurs present on the occasion of the
second meeting of the specialized committee
on citizens' rights
on August 6th, finally, we are
well aware that the current priority and will remain
for the months to come to deal
with this unprecedented
health crisis in  because of the empty coc and
all its economic and
social consequences which are very serious
forgiveness nevertheless despite this priority
there is the crisis of the empty
coc realism leads us to prepare ourselves
also and at the same time for the great
changes which will take place on the 1st
next January,
that is to say on the date chosen by the
United Kingdom for the economic principle
and the bric commercial site with or without a
commercial agreement
there will be significant changes
it is the direct consequence of the break
site and that is why the commission has
started a virtual tour of the capitals a few days ago
to accompany
the national administrations and all
the economic sectors that are
exposed in the United Kingdom we have therefore
published a readiness communication in 23
languages
anied by detailed sectoral notices which
take up the main chang
s and which clearly identify with
egard to all the actors of the Europ
an Union the measures which must be taken
by the companies  by the
administrations and other
stakeholders in order to prepare for this
inevitable is clearly a new
situation
on 1 January next, ladies
and gentlemen, here is what I am going to tell you at the
end of this round
the next meeting is planned in the
form of a return  week of
September 7, of
course, in the meantime, we will
continue with davy trust and his team
our work our dialogue
throughout the next two weeks,
but beyond the
negotiation process beyond the
agenda issues
it is on substantive issues  the
one I reminded in particular that we
must now progress and to
conclude yes the weekend  ll well well known
brother of clock is ticking of stick sketches
all the documents are useful and we
actually received this week
new British documents on the
British positions which are sometimes
confirmed often confirmed sometimes
amended correct all that is useful to
better understand  understand and to
clarify positions, but I simply want to recall
one thing that must be well
understood and which is sometimes not well
understood, although we have been repeating it
for four years and although
we have confirmed it by the 27 heads of state of
government unanimously the
European parliament, particularly in my mandate,
a trade agreement must
include three inseparable elements
what we proposed in an
absolutely new way since we
had never done at the start of the
trade negotiations
what we proposed to the kingdom  -uni
0 tariff zero quotas for the exchange of
goods
second element an agreement to develop
a line that guarantees that we
have more fair play
ic between two partners who are
extremely close 0 km between the
single market in ireland and the united kingdom and
who have had very important exchanges
for a very long time and we
third because it  is also linked
to the economy to trade it is the
issue of fisheries we want a
balanced agreement
these three elements are inseparable
so it is always useful that the
united kingdom reminds us on trade in
goods and services
these demands its  positions but we can
only work on a consolidation of
text on the fact together and not
everyone at home unilaterally and on
the fact on all the subjects that
make up this package because it is
inseparable at the moment and clear
I repeat a new  times so that it
is well understood if the united kingdom wants
a trade agreement with the
european union 0 tariff zero quotas this
agreement must include a credible framework
and  operational level playing field
the rules of the economic game to avoid
to control the risks the
humbling against each other and must
include a balanced agreement on
fisheries
and this is not the case with the documents that
we have received so I have  repeated that
david frost and I'll tell you again
I'm not sure I understood
your question but I'll try to
answer it
and then if they wanted to
speak again to clarify we are
working well and what we
want to achieve  it is an agreement on
the most important subject and you
have three main series of subjects which
are part of those comprehensive
partnership which are trade 0 tariff
zero quotas with penfield spur and
the fishing agreement transport issues
in all dimensions
of energy and many other topics
related to mobility in particular
and then finally issues related to
internal security which is very
important for our citizens in the  two
sides a subject on which we have
worked a lot to
clarify progress since the start of
this second negotiation on the future
relationship but you
have identified the most
important subjects trade is obviously the heart of
this foundation of this future partnership and I
I told you Thursday to your colleague your
colleague earlier the conditions
for reaching a trade agreement which
are those of my mandate
it seems more in front of Senegal
but no it was not necessary when the stand
during the court without being good  to indulge
in a hockey head
it's a phrase is only usual to
say there won't be agreement on anything
if there isn't agreement on everything i
believe we are  agree on this
question with them on this method with
the British
me what matters to me is what the
first British person says whom I listen to with
great attention and who we
have exchanges with elsewhere and the price
public in belfast last week  era
when he encountered the small shock
clearly recalled that he wanted an
agreement with the European union
that is what is important for me and
I understand it moreover because
an agreement ensures a certain economic stability
a disagreement  on the other hand, when we
look at the structure of trade between
the United Kingdom and the European Union,
I have always said, for
four years here, there would be a lot of
consequences of
legal, social and political economic turbulence, no
doubt, so it is in the interest.  common
that's what the first meant
that's what's important to me so
we keep this perspective because
it's also ours that's the meaning
of the mandate that was given to me  by the 27
Heads of State of Government and also
by the European Parliament but it wo
n't be an agreement at any price you
have to understand that we will not pay
to have a gap with the British the
price of weakening the single market does not
will not take the risk
by opening our markets without arriving without
quotas or the British to weaken
or compromise thousands of jobs
at home or to lower
social rights environmental rights
we want these relations in
the United Kingdom to be balanced we have no
not afraid of competition
ursula von der leyen said it clearly competition
is part of life
but our whole philosophy
is that this
competition must be fair and our
philosophy to use a word that
the british use  quite often
at the moment and I am not against
philosophical reflections
it is precisely what I call this
new generation of trade agreements
and that is why this agreement does
not bring together what we did
fifteen or twenty years ago  or even more
recently with some other more
distant countries is less important
economically in our relations with
us we want  new agreements
that correspond to today's times
and we therefore take into account the
concerns of citizens everywhere that
I hear that I listen to that are
organized on
fair play and economic requirements in terms
of the environment  of social
rights of consumer rights of climate
change
so here it is therefore
not sorry for this rather
general answer but it is important to of course
there are a lot of details in the
negotiation of course I know the
tactic which consists in delaying or in
isolate certain subjects to do I don't
know what bargaining my only concern
is to remember that we are talking
about very complex subjects in particular on
fishing where it is a question of 100 species of
fish without species of fish we are
talking about very complex subjects at the  legal plan with
regard to the level playing
field of state aid we are waiting to
understand what the
British policy will be in terms of
stage rules or name  many
clauses it takes time it takes
time
we have very good lawyers on
both sides but they have to
know which way to work
so I am worried and worried
disappointed because I see this time
passing and we are taking are starting to take
risks on the ability to achieve
ratification of the treaty
at the end of the year this is what I
think good strike 5th knicks have
no answers very brief situation will
change
we remain available is a subject of
interest to all  member states which,
it seems to me, is also of interest to the
United Kingdom as having a preventive framework
for all practical purposes of cooperation
between us in the field of
development, particularly in Africa
political cooperation United Nations or
in sensitive regions
we can clearly see that  at the moment like the
mediterranean to allow, if the
united kingdom wishes, cooperation in
terms of external intervention
sometimes these
are subjects where I think that we  our
interest would be to have a framework that is
usable rather than improvising
at the very moment of a crisis, that's my
experience as Minister of Foreign
Affairs a few years ago that
makes me think that and I understand that he
doesn't  does not want to discuss this it is his
choice it takes two to discuss
but it will undoubtedly be the subject of
discussions of subsequent negotiations
after the conclusion of this base of
the partnership agreement on
economic issues and security issues
but the European Union remains available
and interested in cooperation with the
United Kingdom on these major subjects which
affect the stability in one way or
another of our continent and have been able to
ensure this stability only together with
the United Kingdom.
is also true for the question of
defense that I mentioned earlier